[Music]
hello everyone we are here to talk about
spark on Google Cloud I'm Abhishek
kashyap and I lead product management
for dataproc at Google Cloud we also
have one of our customers
with us
thank you Abhishek my name is I lead the
Big Data infrastructure team at Live app
I'm really excited to talk about our
journey to gcp and data proc
thank you Mithun for joining us and
thank you to the audience for watching
we have some exciting content in story
for you we'll start with the brief
introduction of Open Source analytics on
Google Cloud we'll share what's new with
serverless spark followed by what's new
with security and governance
finally for the most exciting part of
this presentation Mithun will share live
ramps experience with Google Cloud
specifically with data box Spark
as many of us realize we are living in
the Golden Age of Open Source as it is
now being pervasively used across
Enterprises and the adoption is only
accelerating in fact 99 of Fortune 500
companies use open source today with 80
planning to further increase it in the
next 12 months as companies double down
on their open source Investments they no
longer see them as a separate corner of
their data architecture instead they are
looking for ways to integrate open
source analytics and processing into the
core of their data platform
at Google Cloud we have long focused on
enabling customers to modernize their
open source deployments with cloud data
block our managed open source offering
customers like Metro Vodafone and live
Ram
are using Cloud dataproc to modernize
their data analytics infrastructure to
simplify their operations lower support
cost and infrastructure costs and
greatly improve the robustness of their
data analytics ecosystem as we have been
in this journey over the past five years
we have learned a lot from helping
customers migrate some of the largest
open source deployments in the world to
Google Cloud
one Trend that stood out is the
popularity of spark we have a dedicated
focus on spark at Google Cloud a
commitment to making spark a first-class
citizen
within gcp for all your workloads be it
ETL data science or data exploration
there are three key pillars to our spark
support the foundation is an auto
scaling serverless Park offering for all
your workloads we are bringing the same
Simplicity you are used to with some of
our native cloud services to spark
taking away the manual coil and
complexity typically associated with
spark deployments
the second pillar is having spark being
pervasive with our Market leading
services like bigquery vertex AI
composer and dataplex now data Engineers
data scientists and developers can all
seamlessly use spark in their tools of
choice across all of their data
and last but not the least we give you
the flexibility in how you consume spark
in addition to serverless you can deploy
spark on compute engine or on kubernetes
now you have a full spectrum of
offerings to fit your needs
a serverless spark for ETL jobs is
generally available we have seen strong
adoption
from customers for the their data
processing pipelines as an example openx
has migrated a lot of the ETL pipelines
to serverless spark and is seeing a
reduction in cost due to 100 percent
infrastructure utilization that they
achieve in the serverless model as well
as increase developer productivity as no
one has to manage clusters anymore
we also have Partners who are ready to
work with you
in implementing serverless spark in your
environment
now let's look at what's new
we have implemented spark natively in
the bigquery API and I'll share the
details shortly
for serverless spark we have also added
custom executor shapes for your jobs
that require high or low memory
you can now customize your auto scaling
speed through spark properties
and finally for serverless spark you can
now stream custom containers to all the
workers to significantly lower the
startup latency
on the security and governance side you
can get fine-grained governance
for files using spark through big lake
you can automate policy management
across your Fleet of dataproc clusters
and finally you can Federate bigquery
metadata in real time with the data proc
managed Hive meta store
for your spark applications to work
seamlessly with bigquery
foreign
bigquery and Spark together
your data engineers and data scientists
can now create external stored
procedures in bigquery
by writing spark code and they can
publish them for data analytic analysts
to use in their SQL analytics and
dashboards
and
what's more you can actually use your
bigquery reservations for these spark
workloads and all bigquery security
policies that you set up will apply to
spark as well with that I would like to
share a demo with you
this is the familiar bigquery console as
you can see
there is an external spark stored
procedure in the left nav and you can
see that by spark code here
you can change the name of the stored
procedure and when you click run it will
create a new spark stored procedure for
you in bigquery the new one shows in the
left nav which you can then run using
serverless Spark by just invoking that
sort procedure
what more you can create a new scheduled
query Within bigquery
do you schedule it as a pipeline right
from bigquery as well
that was the demo let's now talk about
interactive development to serverless
spark your data scientists can now go to
their Jupiter notebooks and develop on
demand there is no need to create
underutilized clusters and keep them
running the whole time for development
purposes
serverless Park through Jupiter
notebooks is natively integrated with
vertex AI workbench so with vertex here
workbench you can now develop the spark
together with other ml Frameworks like
tensorflow Pi torch SQL learn and even
bigquery ml and once you are ready to
deploy these models you can just create
serverless spark components
through your kubeflow based AI pipelines
and again without having to create any
clusters you can execute your mlops
pipelines on demand
to help you get started we have a width
set of Pi spark and Java open source
templates which you can use as
executable code and you can use them
through notebooks as well
moving on to the security features
the most exciting is the ability to use
spark with a variety of open data
formats and apply to go and column level
accounts to files in that format and
this is achieved through data clock
integration with big lake
furthermore you can govern all your data
from a single pane of class with
dataplex
we are also making it easy for you to
create and apply policies
for your Fleet of clusters automatically
you can create policies for resource
management security standardization or
even for standardization of components
you want within your dataproc clusters
at a project level and you can then
manage them across your organization
last but not the least you can now
access bigquery metadata from the data
block managed Hive meta store in real
time you can even do ddl and DML on
bigquery data directly from your spark
with that I would like to invite Mython
to talk about live wrap thank you again
Mithun for partnering with us at next
22. to kick it off can you please tell
us about lifegraph
thank you Abhishek
and you talked about some great
technology features that enable faster
and easy data processing but on data
side collaboration is still pretty
complex right when it comes to
collaboration you using the customer
data it is even more complex for
organizations right so when we talk
about customer data there could be
offline attributes like name address
email phone number the change over time
don't have consistent representation and
Online attributes like IP address and
device ID have the same issue right so
this is where live Ram can help we
replace those inconsistent attribute
with safe secure easy and and and
consistent identifier that can be used
to join data across your organizations
that was very contextual information
method thank you
can you tell us more about your team and
the data and Technology landscape at
library
sure we are a Global Group or group of
Engineers that apart from the other
things work on large and complex
infrastructure to process petabytes of
data on a daily basis we have one of the
biggest identity graph in the industry
so unlike other like analytics problems
in the industry which are mostly map and
reduce our problem is map and join right
so and we do it at a large scale so we
have built some custom tooling and
libraries for that I'll talk a little
bit more about it we mostly use open
source Technologies and most of our
products have multi-cloud support
thank you
yeah that is significant scale and
complexity
you did migrate from on-premises Hadoop
to cloud data proc about one and a half
years ago can you share how your journey
was
it was exciting we had a lot of
learnings on the way so we started off
working very closely with gcp we did
several pocs and that Drew our Target
architecture and overall approach we
made some very critical decisions early
on that really set the stage for us so
one of the decision is instead of having
a single monolithic cluster that is
supported by the central team we moved
to f a barrel clusters that are owned by
individual teams that basically
transferred the power back to the
engineering teams and it also reduced
the blast radius for like poorly
configured or poorly implemented jobs we
also invested a lot of time and energy
into building self-service service
tooling that basically reduce the time
to market for engineers and also made
our workload consistent or processing
pipelines consistent as I mentioned
earlier we have the one of the biggest
Industries map join kind of use case so
we built a Java based custom library on
top of Spark It's called mapsite join
Library one of our Engineers will be
writing a Blog on it pretty soon but
that really helped
make our pipelines efficient
that's great thank you
can you share what has worked well and
what are some of the benefits that you
have realized
yeah so we we met with gcp team we meet
with them they have been really great
support Amazon partner through this
whole journey and even now right so we
meet with them on a weekly basis we work
very closely with them on a quarterly
basis in defining each other's roadmap
or influencing each other's roadmap I
would say so one example is driver pool
uh that's that we were able to influence
dataprox roadmap to include that uh
include that and Implement that uh right
so apart from that cost was a biggest
biggest requirement for us so we
implemented tagging reporting alerting
that helped us attribute the cost to the
lowest asset asset level asset grain so
that really help
we as I mentioned we did Implement a lot
of tooling terraform for class creation
was a what was a major uplift for the
engineers basically you could use that
terraform to create clusters and that
would uh that that would have all the
plumbing necessary to work within the
live Ram ecosystem right and after the
migration once we reached a reliable uh
configuration right we spent a lot of
time on cost tuning right we use all the
leverages like on-demand versus pvm node
type Disk type disk space
decommissioning time scale up time we
used all these parameters to come arrive
at a very optimal configuration for our
workloads that is both reliable and cost
efficient in some cases we have saved
more than 30 percent on cost and
improved efficiency by 10x
thank you for sharing these
next we would love to know where you are
headed
sure yeah we are working now we are
working very closely with nvd and gcp uh
we are on Cutting Edge uh path over here
we are looking to run some of our
complex workloads on GPU using nvidia's
Rapids accelerator Library uh we have
made we have been doing that POC for a
quarter now uh we have made tremendous
uh contributions to the to the Rapids
Library and we are hoping to go live
with one of our workload on that pretty
soon
and as I mentioned we will be migrating
to driver pool the feature that we
worked with dataproc on uh and we are
also we have like workloads that are
like very small to very large so for
some of these small workloads that
complete within five minutes we are
looking to move them to serverless data
proc
um pretty soon
thank you for sharing this method
as one last question would you like to
share any lessons from your migration to
Cloud
yeah there have been a lot uh it has
been a good journey so one one thing the
primary thing I would say is Benchmark
Benchmark Benchmark so as they say you
can't improve what you can't measure so
having a good understanding of your
workload before migration is very
important so generate that Benchmark and
also with any migration project
especially the complex com with all the
complexities it is important to focus on
one thing so what we did was we said
reliability of was our focus with same
cost and then we we basically worked on
the cost post migration
so
and another cool thing that you get with
a good relationship with gcp is preview
preview of all the new features that are
coming along right so even though there
is no guarantee that all the features
will be same at GA it is important that
you engage early on and like influence
the features to make sure that they meet
your need especially the features that
you are uh you that that you are very
interested in right so another thing on
the cost custom committed uses discounts
they they save money
but spot VMS save even even more money
and one one thing to note is like spot
VMS don't count for committed use
discounts that you have purchased so it
is very important to understand your
workload and buy the committed used
discounts only to the level that you can
you would spend right so you would the
way would you would go understand your
whole uh workload and then understand
how much of that will be your spot
instances and how much of that leftover
would you want to buy committed use
discounts
wow those were some great insights with
them thank you for joining us and thanks
to the audience for joining us have a
great guest of next 22.
[Music]